I did study the gene Kelly's of the
world in Fred Astaire's I've probably
seen almost every every single YouTube
tap thing he's so talented and he is
picking it up so fast and working
incredibly hard and he's dancing with
some of the best tappers I know I in no
way shape or form knew how hard it was
going to be I just figured that I could
learn the tap movement and it would make
the sound but what I found is that you
really need to be musical tapping is
playing the drums with your feet I mean
you're a percussionist really you're
it's at you're musician I don't even
think they should call it tap dancing
they should just call it like foot
percussion or something cuz it you are
dancing but really you're playing a part
of the song he's dancing on tables he's
dancing on bars he's dancing on stools
he's hanging from fixed objects on the
ceiling I mean he's like Donald O'Connor
Gene Kelly Fred Astaire kind of all
smashed into one number
now we flood the bar with like 15 to 20
more by the end of the number and their
swing dancing and doing cliffs and
everything not only are we doing a
classic number we get to show how these
classic numbers were made in one fell
swoop there's a moment where you're
gonna see a camera shooting the guy's
close then we cut and you'll see the
camera moving back and the set moving
together as the camera backs out I got a
lot of friends in the real dance world
and they all love tap dancing but there
just isn't any jobs for tap dancing it's
a dream come true it truly is like the
dream job for kind of everything that I
trained to do I get to do what I grew up
watching and falling in love with with
like this is why I dance is watching
Gene Kelly Fred Astaire and all those
big classic movies
to get to recreate something like that
or pay homage to something like that in
a movie and pulling out the stops that
we're pulling out is just I couldn't ask
for anything better really you
you